the picture i showed you before
this was taken on an iphone 7 plus
the earth
is a very small stage
the only home
we've ever known
[Music]
additional equipment
[Music]
so have you ever wondered about those
shot on iphone commercials or about any
of those shot on any smartphone
commercials are those clips
actually shot on smartphones well the
answer is technically yes but often with
some heavy adaptation a lot of times you
can get a perfect shot out of a
smartphone with just the camera handheld
in perfect conditions no problem but
that's pretty rare and you can often
guarantee a much better shot if you have
a little gear with you so take this
example of a video shot entirely on
phones some of the shots are literally
just a smartphone so a smartphone on a
selfie stick or a smartphone on a mount
no special attachment needed but a lot
of other shots get much more complicated
smartphone on a tiny drone smartphone on
a much bigger drone smartphone attached
to a cine lens with a wireless follow
focus on a gimbal attached to a
motorized remote control four wheeled
skateboard
that is a lot so at the end of the video
or the commercial or whatever you're
watching you see shot on a smartphone
and a main point of those commercials is
that you see that it's shot on a
smartphone that you can get it's
supposed to make you feel like you can
make movies just like that because you
get that same smartphone but when you
see the behind the scenes of how a lot
of these shots go down and how these
things are made it can actually kind of
have the opposite effect that kind of
stuff is not available for 99 of us mere
mortals to use but there is luckily for
us quite a bit of dope tech that can uh
bring a lot of that down to the consumer
level and help us maximize our
smartphone cameras smartphone cameras
are obviously for the most part really
good they're also the most popular
camera in the world at this point and
you may have heard the saying that the
best camera is the one you have with you
i think that's true
but of course you like to take it to the
next level so for photos obviously the
sensor and the glass on the front of it
are the only permanent thing about a
smartphone camera lens adapter systems
out there exist to add another layer to
that so there's a bunch of different
styles out there clip-on versions bumper
versions case holster versions this one
i've grown to like the most is the
moment lenses so that's actually the new
version the moment v2 and i've
gravitated towards this one mostly
because of their focus on quality it
does require a case which acts as the
lens mount and then these tiny cine
lenses mount to the case to change the
field of view the focal length and the
capabilities of this camera entirely
there's an 18 millimeter lens which is a
little wider than the normal field of
view there's a super wide angle fisheye
version there's even a 10 times macro
lens that can get some crazy close-up
shots so this i think is pretty awesome
now the fact that you need a whole case
to be the lens mount instead of you know
maybe just like a little clip-on
accessory means you are a bit restricted
it means when you upgrade your phone you
have to get a whole new case so that's
the downside but the benefit is the
precision so you mount the lens over the
exact center of the sensor every single
time there's never any vignetting in the
corners no loss of sharpness anywhere in
the frame they're polarized lenses too
so in terms of really upping the quality
game from the camera of photos these are
pretty dope these in particular support
a couple of phones but not all of them
in fact some i thought they would
support they don't but they said it's
because they actually wouldn't be a
precise fit or they would have some
vignetting or it's not practical so they
have a couple you can check out if
they're compatible with yours and i was
never really into these before as like a
cheap alternative to dslrs but when you
think about it that's exactly what these
are you can never really match the
quality of a dslr that will always be
better
but this will always be smaller and
always be cheaper now for smartphone
video you add a whole other dimension
you add movement of the camera a big
part of video is movement and you can do
a lot handheld and you can have really
steady hands but after a certain point
you're going to have some shake you're
going to want to stabilize it so taking
videos shot on smartphones to the next
level means taking stabilization to the
next level that's actually where dji
osmo mobile comes in it's pretty much
the standard right now as far as
smartphone stabilization goes this thing
is built specifically to stabilize a
smartphone camera it has some extra
controls on the handle of course which
are nice when it connects your phone
which can trigger to pan left and right
and tilt up and down and get all kinds
of cool shots but mainly the operator
gets to just point and shoot and start
moving and the gimbal smoothes out and
stabilizes all the little twitches and
shakes that come from being handheld and
it works really well and i can add a
whole new dimension to videos or even
live streams or whatever you decide to
shoot on your phone it's just up to you
to decide how to use it now i found that
it doesn't really handle the extra
weight of also adding the moment lenses
to it so you can't use the osmo and your
phone with the lenses at the same time
you need a bigger gimbal that supports a
little bit of a heavier payload like
something like this zuyan tech crane
which is made for actual cameras but the
gorillapod adapter let me put my phone
on it but that's just if you're feeling
daring so bottom line is all this tech
exists to help you take your smartphone
photo and video game to the next level
and of course it's not just about the
gear it's also about the strategy and
all that you know about photography and
video already i could probably make a
whole separate video about just that but
the whole point is yes a dedicated
camera while it's bigger will definitely
do a better job every time in the
quality department that's what it's
built for but your smartphone cameras
will always be at your side they'll
always be smaller and they will always
be cheaper than actually going out and
buying a separate camera system so while
it might not seem super practical to
actually go out and be able to shoot
those commercial level crazy high-end
videos that people are doing with
technically smartphone sensors on crazy
rigs and jibs and stuff like that it's
also a lot of fun to try to maximize
what you can do with the tech that's in
your pocket right now and i feel like
that's where a lot of people i tell is
to start your youtube channel with your
smartphone camera you should see my
inbox like every day there's questions
about i have this gear and this lens is
this enough to start a youtube channel
right now
yes you're probably already set if you
can watch this video on something you
probably have a device that can shoot
video just start doing it right i'm
going to end this before i start renting
that's pretty much it thank you for
watching this quick one and i'll talk to
you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]